May in um this
is it doesn't unnecessary but you are so
um welcome all to
the the licensing committee meeting
um the agenda can I have the apologies
for absence then please thank you chair
apologies from councelor hackit and
councelor
Thomas okay
um
minutes page 3 to
five I you've all had a chance to look
through this is there anything that
anybody's got a concern
with I I'll propose from the chair that
we accept them I got a second
there Council
Pender no we take a vote sorry those in
favor and against
abstention
excellent so we'll move to the action
list page six which is against me and
Chris oh I've started draft writing a
letter but I'm waiting for some stats
from Chris yeah apologies chair I've
been working on some stats on cost of
licenses but I haven't quite finished
that yet so as soon as it's finished
it'll be with you and we can progress
that
marvelous thank you very much
um
top um Declaration of interests well
we're all used to this so if you've got
interested declare make sure you make it
known um agreement between part um part
one and part two CH if I can just just
mention that we got the police licensing
officers coming for a verbal um report
I'm not expecting any part two items but
just be wary if there is any if there's
any specific queries about specific
places we may need to go into part two
but I'm not expecting us to need to well
we'll go with the assumption that we
don't need to at this point and then if
we do we will need to that uh so I'll
propose it we got a seconder for the uh
councel inch and uh in
favor marvelous
unanimous thank you very
much um urg matters to be brought
forward by Commission of the chair and
the committee anything in
particular no right on to number seven
uh taxi policy Amendment uh vehicle
emissions I'll go to Chris on
this yeah thank you chair um yes a
licensing committee approved the most
recent taxi policy on the 22nd of May
2022 that policy introduced a new
standard for vehicle
emissions um and a time scale for the
trade to comply with those emission
standards um I have the license team
have received a request from the taxi
Lea on committee to extend those time
scales for compliance with the new
standards um the taxi trades have stated
that following the impact of the coid
pandemic Demand on taxes has still not
returned to um pre pandemic levels the
nighttime economy is particularly still
very um low and the main mainly because
the main nightclub in the town has not
reopened since it was in forced closure
during coid so that the nighttime
economies particularly been hit um the
tax trades have also stated that cost of
living crisis has made a significant
impact um the cost of new and second
cars have
increased um there's there's not been
sufficient progress in respect of charge
points and availability of coste
effective um electric cars they're a bit
wary on um committing to an electric
vehicle and they're not particularly in
a large rural Authority um with the the
life of the batteries or the length of
time they can drive before having to
recharge with with lack of charge points
um also recently the government
announced that their 2030 Target of um
Banning the sales of petrol and diesel
cars has been extended to
2035 um so the trade as requested that
um we amend the current policy the
current policy states that from April 26
all vehicles licensed by TDC will be
required to meet Euro 6 standards and
then from April 203
um all vehicles licensed for the first
time must meet CO2 emissions are less
than 50 which is in effect um electric
cars um what they have requested is to
extend the dates of those um the
implementation of those requirements to
April
2030 for EUR 6 compliance and April
2035 for the electric vehicle
compliance um they've also mentioned
that the wheelchair access we put in
that all wheelchair accessible Vehicles
will have a two-year allowance on
emissions they said that um that isn't
any benefit really to to wheelchair
accessible Vehicles so they're happy to
to remove that um I did consult with the
council's sustainability and climate
change officer um she said she would be
supportive of the
extension um but was a bit conc
regarding Euro 6 Euro 6 has been around
since about September
2015 um so there are um availability of
euro6 cars um albeit consideration to
what I've said previously about the cost
of secondhand cars and
things um but possibly a sort of
compromise agreement would be that we we
can either retain the 2026 um or
committee might be minded to to pick a
date in between 20 28 for
instance um but we we state that the
2026 deadline would only be for newly
registered
vehicles um so they can keep their
existing Vehicles the concern with the
trade is they've got it they'll get to
that point and they've all got to renew
all their vehicles whereas if we let
them keep their existing Vehicles it'll
only be when that vehicle comes to the
end of its life that then it has to be
renewed with a with a Euro 6
vehicle um there's also the possibility
that they could come to committee if
they if they meet that 2026 deadline
they have got financial difficulties or
whatever they could come to a licensing
subcommittee and that could be
determined at a licensing subcommittee
on a on a Case by casee basis which is a
a process you know you may want to put
in
place um so really over to to the
committee to decide um firstly do you
want to go with the the um tax Aon
committees
request for April 2030 and April 35
dates or do you want to do a sort
of in between that even go or you could
retain the 2026 as is or make the
Amendments um I've suggested um through
okay over to
the it's up to the chair chair sea Moy
is a member of the taxi L on committee
yeah Jo
in just for recording
purposes thank
you if we stay with the 2026 deadline
for euro6
vehicles and but we just did what bars
will do which is continuous plating your
existing Vehicles until as Chris says
they reach the end of their natural Life
by then every vehicle on the road is
going to be a EUR 6 anyway there'll be
very few
older vehicles still
running personally I couldn't afford to
change all my vehicles for Euro 6 at
this time and even in two years time the
way the economy is going it's not
working for us and we've all got the
same problem if we could do continuous
if you want to bring in the 2026 date
fine but leave existing vehicles on
continuous plating until they reach
their end of the natural life and have
to be changed then you can carry on
forward with the rest of it
I don't know if that makes sense to
anybody
but yeah Gibson may I ask a question of
the liaison officer what's the expected
life of a taxi from between 10 and 15
years most of the taxis on the road at
the moment are pushing 10 years old so
with five or six years they're going to
be off the road anyway yeah okay thank
you so generally you wouldn't have that
much of a problem if we stuck with our
2026 Target with the caveat that only
when they reach the end of their natural
life it would be a perfectly reasonable
I should think very
acceptable um compromise for everybody
okay
um and what about the emissions Levels
by
2035 would that I'm not sure as we stand
at the moment you're talking about going
to electric vehicles well I live in a
flat I have three vehicles I cannot run
cables across the pavement to charge
them there's no charge points where I
live if I do run cables if a faes I'm
pay fine per day per cable for charging
a vehicle by running it across the
pavement no one can afford to do
that I
see okay until they've got sufficient
charge points in place that we can all
use comfortably I it's it is not
workable no no I mean from my point I
kind of wonder if the government's role
back of this is now pushing back
everybody else's like opinion of it as
well that where if we were still aiming
for that original 2030 date maybe we
would have more impetus to get more
charge points in quicker but they
haven't got the to do it that's why
they' pushed it back they haven't got
the infrastructure to put charge points
in in place the other problem with
electric cars is you were lucky to get
200 miles at range on a full charge it's
no good the company saying Oh They'll do
3 400 miles cuz they don't don't live in
a rural area like we do they haven't got
a deal with hills carrying a full load
of passengers all the time it won't work
you'd have to have a very long extension
need to keep the thing on charge all the
time well there is that point where is
yeah I kind of think if you're making a
deadline then you try and get things
done by the deadline if the deadline
moves later you're just going to leave
it5 because there isn't the
infrastructure there so okay the council
can move it back but keep the 2026
deadline for euro6 vehicle
yeah okay well I think that's a happy
medium anyway but I just councel D would
you like to
intervene thank you can I just ask about
um H where hybrid vehicles fit into this
because I absolutely coner with what
you're saying electric vehicles aren't
fit for purpose here for the majority of
residents let alone taxi drivers is
utterly ludicrous and moving the
deadline back once as you say you know
they're going to do it again if the
infrastructure still isn't there and
frankly
I think everyone's seeing sense and
thinking you know the economy isn't up
to standard and fit for
purpose you know how can people afford
to do this it's not it's not logical so
ultimately um I think there must be a
place where the hybrids fit I think
hybrids are a good idea but that again
they're still very expensive at the
moment to buy I got two multiseat R SE
seat of vehicles to replace one them
with a hybrid has sent me back £45,000
second hand
you're looking at 60,000 plus
new if you go electric for the same
Vehicles I'm looking at £80,000 a
vehicle uh Council
Gibson thank you chair um I'm in
transport myself I have been all my life
and I still am and run a fleet of Vans
Nationwide uh did you right quite
rightly point out Euro 6 has been around
since 2015 we've been in compliance with
that for some time now um the life
expectancy of a tax ause says 10 to 15
years yeah if it's properly maintained
well yeah um moving deadlines I think is
a dangerous thing I think they're there
for a reason have been debated
previously and I think they should all
all of them stay including the
26 there's another driver for this
whether it's Vehicles being available
charging points being available is is an
old adage uh necessity is the mother of
invention if that deadline stays the
business your business my business will
find a way you've got to have these
deadlines in place otherwise we'll be
keep moving them back it's sending the
wrong
message well on the
environment could I ask you a question
do you have a yard that you keep your
vehicles in yes we do so you've got the
facility to put in charge points where
the rest of us haven't
yes that's true
yeah yeah
me again pushing back um deadlines as
you said I mean I I kind of think that
you're also pushing back the Economy
based around repairing these charge
points and that later as well you know
they would come forward quicker if they
needed it today you know but if they say
we don't need it for another five years
they don't need it you know they push
the economy on that back five years you
just have a delay but uh yes so was it
can the b in you have your hand up first
um does this apply to private hire yes
as well as taxes so we're covering how
many vehicles would that be Chris we've
got
approximately sorry I'm on still that's
it I'm on now um yeah we got
approximately 130 vehicles in total and
approximately 45 of those are Euro 6 at
the moment so roughly 35% of the trade
is currently EUR
80 80 odd
Vehicles it's to be a lot of money
that's going to out of the the economy
which I find quite a frightening
number secondly I think this has all to
do with the Yu Bridge B action because
the conservatives got back in again on
the back of ules which was a um a
situation that London residents couldn't
stick and I I find if London can't do it
we have a rural area here we're going to
struggle and thirdly um Chris you talked
about the officer um for climate I would
like to see the lead member for economy
make comment here and the lead member
for climate change make comment here
because there's almost two ju positions
and we need are elected members to
actually comment on this and that's what
their job is they've been put in rows of
lead members why are they not commenting
on this this uh
application that's a very good point um
do we have any answer as to that or well
I I'll go with councel level first
before I say the other
thing sorry just I would like to you
know add to the problems that we've got
with the infrastructure supporting
electric vehicles because my
understanding is that um you know the
current infrastructure that we've got
isn't functioning correctly never mind
sufficient um charging points being
available um you know until it's it's
until we
lead on that I think it's quite
understandable that people are not going
to look at electric vehicles because why
would they you know if the existing
infrastructure isn't working and there's
we're going to pull back or or use the
government's thing as an excuse not to
install more which I think they might
well do say well you know the as you say
the deadlines moved I think it's just
going to be a a downward
spiral I think you could be right there
um so I was wondering is there any
mileage interferring until we get the
lead member's role or or do we feel that
we're in a position where we could make
a judgment on this
today well I'll
test chair I will test I'll make a
proposal that we defer until we hear
from the lead from climate and lead from
economy I'll make that a proposal if
somebody else second it and we
defer Council
D I'll make a proposal that we
um accept the latter
deadline
okay coun Gibson go third proposal go on
U my proposal is we accept the
recommendations as set out in the agenda
we stick to the these deadlines current
deadlines well the original ones yes yes
we have another four recommend
okay the existing is
2026 the proposal from the taxi lay on
committee is 2030 I did suggest you may
wish to consider a halfway house and do
a
2028 2030 and 2035 there the two
dates oh so we have got finalized
proposal uh any other seconders
or right well
um we'll go with uh Anna dart's proposal
then um all in favor of Anna's proposal
for 2030 and
2035 okay a two uh
against
okay five and abss none right that's
that's interesting right um let's go
with any other second just for something
currently
standing I
will well go C LEL go
then do you want I I I'm happy to the
2026 with vehicles being updated
as as as they've ended up but I think we
should hold on to the
for now
just to see if that provides an impetus
to get the impet to sorted out you would
be seconded essentially what councelor
Gibson's already putting
forward because that's what you said beg
you pardon did you say I do beg you
pardon I do beg you pardon I didn't I'm
misconstrued I thought he was
saying oh sorry would you be happy to
second that then so it's 26 and and as
as and when they come into thingy and
holding on to the 2030 is that what
you're saying I do beg you pardon yes
I'll second it
got I I'll just mention that the the
full taac this is came in these
proposals came in as part of the full
policy review the next full policy
review is during
2025 so there will be a full review of
the policy and potentially these dates
you're agreeing now in 2025 just to make
you aware of that so anything you put
you decide today won't necessarily be
said in stone as the full policy will'll
be out to consultation and review in
2025 I still think it's important to
show a direction councel
level sorry so what you're saying is
that we can keep that
2030 hope that
that inspires the council to sort out
infrastructure but if it hasn't then
there's a get out clause that you can
move it to 35 because you're not ready
is that what you're
saying yes or reaffirm that we are
committed to that date but yes that's
that's the point um so does does it does
it mean anything is it going to is it
going to drive the council forward on
this I will the 2026 date does need to
be decided because 20 obviously 2025 is
only one one year so the 2026 dates that
wouldn't give them so we do need to
decide on the 2026 date yeah no I I I'm
I'm happy with that but there is scope
with that's important um sooner the
better but I also would like the 2030
thing to be meaningful in the sense of
driving the council forward to putting
in the infrastructure that's then going
to make people feel
comfortable moving towards cleaner cars
I don't
anyway I mean I I feel that the pro that
proposal would definitely show that
trajectory I mean yeah okay we can alter
it 2025 but a little bit too late really
if you're thinking about replacing your
car before 2026 you've probably either a
committed to it or B you were just going
to gamble on not committed to it anyway
you know whichever way you look at it so
I kind of think yeah we could move it
but either way it's important that we
still have a mark in the sand to go to
yeah but I mean if if if in the back of
your mind it work actually it doesn't
really matter cuz I got a back out
clause um because you know we can we can
just say oops a daisy We Didn't Do It um
and and know that that's oh I don't know
anyway yes I'm seconding that one go for
can your level that would be up to
counselors to push that
forward
yeah and it would still be us
so it's up to us to Chang our opinion by
them but um okay well we've got another
proposal so I'll go for those in favor
of keeping the 2026 and the 2030
deadlines with the cavat that there only
once the cars reach end the life that
they need to be updated so those in
favor got
four yes so kind a
level and
against
three no exensions so um that motion is
carried so we got to the bottom of that
one sorry chair can I just clarify the
what's been
agreed so I know we've bounded lots of
dates around so my understanding is
we're sticking with the 2026 date yep
but they can keep their existing
vehicles to Ender life yeah after 2026
yeah and we stick with the 2030 for
electric vehicles
yeah and again they keep their existing
vehicles to end their life yes fine
okay can I just say ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for letting me speak
and it's been a pleasure to be here I'm
always happy for public participation we
need more of it very rarely happens at
Council thank you very much I'm sorry to
take up your time with
this thank you very much for your input
thank
you all right so we moves on
to right that's we will
move to uh agenda
item oh eight other items for taxi
meeting yes go for it yes at that taxi
meeting that we discussed those there
were a few other issues that were
discussed and they were discussed at the
previous Council so I thought it was
worth bringing it to the attention of
the existing committe well you know the
new committee now and just to update on
progress of where we are with things um
one thing was requested was a bus
shelter at the taxi rank at the moment
there's there's only some seats there
and some of the former councilors were
also blyford Town Council Members and
they pursued that through bilford Town
Council and I understand that bilford
Town Council have approved the funding
of that but they're waiting approval
from Devon County Council to run with it
so obviously it's Devon County Council
land um so if they get once they get
approval from Devon County Council they
can pursue the um bus shelter at the
taxi rank for people you know to
obviously to shelter when it's when it's
wet um there's also request for
replacement
signage um but that's on hold to the bus
shelters so if the bus shelter gets
fixed obviously we can um replace
signage as part of the the bus
shelter
improvements um another issue that was
raised at the last meeting was toilet
facilities on bidy for
key um they're obviously working late at
night but the toilets are locked at at
6: PM I did discuss this with the
operational Services team um but that
was a decision made due to vandalism and
antisocial behavior um is the reason why
public toilets are now locked at 6 so
it's unlikely we can pursue
that um and the other issue they raised
was to consider taxi ranks at Westwood
ho and
appledore um this has been raised before
um the issue with providing taxi ranks
is on street parking is Devon County
Council off street parking is Tores
District Council Council um both bodies
charge for parking spaces so if they
give up parking spaces for taxi rank
they are losing incom in effect from
that
space um but I'm going to pursue that
again with those two body I would speak
to our car Parks team and Devon County
Council and inquire once again whether
there is any possibility of Taxi ranks
in westw and hle door but which I'll
bring back to this committee which may
need a discussion at some point um so
yeah just to update the committee on
those
discussions um well I was going to ask
on that um with regards to the toilets
could they be given disabled keys to use
a disabled toilet so it's just available
for just
them that might minimize vandalism to
anything
else so would you be able to look into
that and see if that can be done so a
small movement in the right direction
but
um assume there's no is there a need for
us to either show support for or against
the bus shelter at this stage or
progress this stage I think
progession I think we we can put some
pressure on as a Comm okay cool uh and
Cel
level sorry I just feel it's like you
know access to public toilets is really
important and we're really bad in this
country for that and to just sort of say
oh
well vandalism and and and whatever
Behavior shrug your shoulders and say
that's why we're lock them up we'll end
up with no toilets because of vandalism
and we need to address in some way the
problems of vandalism of the public
toilets and you know I don't know
whether it's by lighting by patrolling
by whatever but I think it's a you know
nobody wants you know you're going to
get upset of people are peeing in door
shock doorways you know or bobbing down
in the park or whatever they're going to
have to do but you know human beings
have to go to the toilet and we've got
to you know provide the facilities for
them and I think just to say oh dear
somebody doesn't treat it properly
therefore we won't have any is not
acceptable it's not enough we' got to do
something positive about it
sorry that's my opinion C
do as I understand it the toilets were
such that you wouldn't actually want to
go in them because of the presence of
certain people lingering within them um
so there was a bit it wasn't just the
state of the toilets it was actual
intimidation on entering the toilets
which I think is more of
a police issue a bigger problem yeah a
police I was why aren't we asking the
police to come and sort it out I don't
know um you just accepting it and then
saying oh you know we don't like people
hanging about then we need to do
something about it not just R shoulders
and lock the toilet that um you wouldn't
well certainly the person I spoke to who
went in there didn't go in there and
went out again you know they just didn't
feel safe in them it was a safety issue
um so somehow that needs to be addressed
I agree with you absolutely okay you're
going bring in sayy at this point so we
do have the toilets are open during the
day and they are shut at 6 p.m. and the
reason they are shut at 6 p.m. is we
have had severe antisocial behavior and
some other unpleasant things going on in
the toilet toilets on the key um so we
are working with the police um we've the
community safety team have been working
with the police we've also got pspos on
the site but it's about being there all
the time police can't be there all the
time torage can't be there all the time
um and the use during those those um
evenings is is far less so it was found
more important because ultimately if it
keeps happening it's a service that we
don't have to provide as a as a council
so we could look at shutting the toilets
all together but we have had incidents
of the toilets been smashed up and other
so it's deemed safer to have them shut
during the evening period um obviously
we can have a look at and and ask the
team about whether taxi drivers can have
access but um it's it's been an issue on
the key for some time now um and I know
that our community safety team are
having meetings with the police and it's
raised regularly but it is a
problem thank you very much uh councilor
Gibson um I completely concur to the
reason why the 6 PM closure um you
mentioned about disabled key how does
that actually
work well my understanding is that
there's keys that essentially all the a
people are allowed access to so they can
go in and no one else can they lock it
in and they unlock It Go in unlock
key don't know I assume they apply to
torage
but know now I just wondered if it was
um uh you know a keypad access or
something like that and they had the
code but the where I'm getting to was if
there's going to be some sort of notice
applied to the toilet saying disabled
access is a available by I didn't know
getting the key or phoning this number
or something then it's a good
opportunity to let the public know why
they're closed they're being closed at
6:00 because of the antisocial behavior
and if you do see anything similar to
that please report it rather than just
having them closed and then the public
complain if they realized why they were
closed um then that would help one other
point on the taxi uh just jumping back
to that second you mentioned that uh the
problem with
granting uh taxi rank space uh was lost
Revenue to the council for car parking
but I would have thought that the taxi
rank the taxi Association pays for the
rank space equal to or greater amount
than actually the uh lost revenue from
the car parking spaces um I mean I look
for claric but I think it was that
because it's on highways de County would
be losing Revenue not us and so
therefore well we would make the revenue
from the taxes so but um don't know if
anything agreed on that kind of
adjustment yes whatever land the rank is
on so if it's in the council car no
torage car park it's torage Revenue um
Deon counted on the road is Devon County
so we need permission from the the
appropriate
Authority so really there there's not
much of a barrier apart from Council
decision as to whether we put a taxi
rank on our own car
Parx
okay mean is what where would that go
would that go to like committee I'll
purs it with the car pars team I'll Le
with the car pars team and I'm not sure
what their approval processes are so
with the car pars team okay because as
you point out it may make us more money
by being a tax rank than it would if it
was Garing I don't
know Council benon
go yeah I think we ought to be a bit
careful because Devon County might put
in a charge because we get licensing
money from the taxis and they may want
to cutor that if we uh pursue this
little argument down the line when it
comes to the point so I'm glad our Devon
County councilors never show up um to
meetings cuz they would um probably hit
on this and pick up a little bit of
money for themselves from that point of
view uh from that side um secondly
antisocial Behavior here we have a um
police crime commissioner partnership
that was celled back in October uh
because Toby Davis for whatever reason
decided not to attend surely this should
be a question that we should be raising
because the last time I came into bhood
for an evening was my wife's 60th
birthday and she is now 68 because we
saw fights all the way up and down
Cooper Street when we were in Byford now
we need to address byford's nighttime
economy because I ain't coming into
bidford by the antisocial Behavior
that's come going on here in bidford and
I think we need to ask our our our
partnership with the police and crime
commission P but uh the police um what
exactly is happening here in bidford
because it's not a place I would come to
after 6 o00 particularly winter
time
sorry just come in there um so yeah
you're right we haven't had a a CSP
Community safety partnership meeting in
a little while we have got one now
booked in for the 7th of November with
with Toby so we will be having a meeting
there and we'll be raising um all these
issues we can certainly raise this one
um at that meeting um and get
discussions going on it I back yeah yep
is that the external on partnership
meeting is is that been rearranged from
the 10th I think was the 10th or the
12th of October it was celled yes it's
the rearranged meeting it's the
rearranged meeting yes it's happening
think I'm pretty sure it's the 7th of
November sorry okay can we then from
this meeting actually ask a question at
that meeting please so that the message
is really put forward strongly at that
meeting uh Stacy do you want to come in
yeah you can um um we do have the
community safety partnership meeting and
we also have other meetings with the
police but what I'm going to say
is the crime stats have actually gone
down quite substantially so it's either
the crime isn't happening or those
incidents aren't being reported and I
think it's really important to get
across that people must log it and I
know um there's been problems with 101
it's I'm being told it's got better but
until those crime I don't actually I say
until I don't want the crime stats to go
up don't get me wrong but what we're
hearing or what's in reports isn't
what's being seen on the ground as it
were so I think anyone must report any
incidents that they see um going forward
so that we can then push forward with
the and push forward with the funding
opportunities because that's partly why
we lost out because I think members may
know obviously B all got here or North
Devon we didn't because our stats
weren't high enough which is kind of a
posit is a positive but if it's not
revealing the true issues then obviously
it's it's not so yeah
yeah um I know uh that the 101 is not
working uh my daughter's uh car was uh
broken into about 6 weeks ago at a
forestry when she's walking the dog and
uh her bags and everything was Nick they
smashed the glass she rang and rang and
rang she went into hos the police
station nobody there and she in the end
just gave up and and and I've heard that
I mean we've had four or five break-ins
in that
Forest out out between our two Wards and
uh and uh nothing absolutely nothing and
pcsos they're a myth in in the sticks
they're just a dream they don't even
come to the
meetings no not happy with the police at
all I don't think they're worth the
money no I mean got to be honest I hear
a lot of people say they tried to report
but just couldn't you know cuz the
system will let them or they just sat
hanging on the phone for so long well
I'm bit surprised that the police hasn't
done anything to try and rectify it
because they've known about this for
what eight nine years now I don't know
quite a long time that they could have
made a bit of a turnaround on that it's
a bit frustrating
um um yeah because I've actually taken
to the point where people report things
to me and I said oh you try they say I
tried and I just email some of the
officers direct but that's not really a
route because that's not really going
for the system the right way at least
they've got ideas of occurring but it
isn't actually reported for a databased
system that this is an actual crime
because obviously I can't report the
crime because I wasn't actually involved
so it's a bit of a complicated work
around but it is just the fact that the
police reporting system is completely
inadequate on all levels as far as I'm
concerned um I think we should probably
make representation to Toby about all
that which I think we did at full
Council actually when he came a few
months ago c d go for it dare I suggest
that it might be to the police's
Advantage if their report of crime are
down you
know sorry can I just correct the record
a second there sorry the the community
safety partnership Mee is on the 9th not
the 7th of November sorry I've just
looked in my calendar um and that is not
the external scrutiny meeting that you
were referring to so that will take
place after that that's yet to be uh
rearranged so the the meeting that was
recently cancelled that you were just
referring to apologies um that will take
place they're planning towards the end
of November is what they've said and
North Devon are going to be a joint yes
yeah that will be a joint with North de
the police um yeah so very
yes sorry chair with your permission can
I just I mean there's huge concern out
there because the the police are setting
a precept way over and above 5% every
year year on year on year and the
services from the police seem to be
getting less and less and it focuses
back on what's happening in bidford
because bidford needs to have a good
economy but people don't come because of
what's happening in bidford and we need
to really make that point and it's been
echoed that the toilets have been you
know vandalized on I don't know how many
occasions but you must have recorded
them surely and that in itself is
evidence of of what's Happening Here in
the
town you to go I don't have the figures
today um they've been vandalized and
we've had some severe antisocial
Behavior with intervenous drug use um
and to try and stop that we put
different lighting in so that I'm not an
expert on these things but so that they
can't see to get a vein but the the
paraphernalia that was left in the
toilets as well consistently as
councelor Dart said no one's going to
want to go in there or take their
children in there because of what what
was found
there
councelor Harden and hopefully we can
move on we've had a good rant now but
can we get back on to the agenda because
nothing we can do no that's fair point
um so yes we'll go on to item nine the
uh licensing act policy
review is it possible chair if we just
bring forward item 10 because Paul
Butler is here from don't Grill him
about issues you police licensing
officer he's in
licensing he's not a normal
PC yes to save him waiting if we go
through item nine if we could just bring
forward item 10 forward do we need to we
need to vote for that or is it think you
can agree to yeah that's fine then
that's no problem yeah if we'll skip to
item 10 then uh police licensing officer
role
cheers thank
you morning morning
morning
okay um I've got a a diet tribe here
that one of my colleagues um has put
together um I've read through it this
morning and yes some of it is very
relevant but a lot of it is not so I
will go for a complete tangent so I do
apologize
okay right so morning my name is Paul
Butler I'm one of the alcohol licens and
officers for Devon corwall um as you can
imagine it is quite a dry subject the
licensing
act um bought in in
2003 uh so our department our licensing
team within daver Cornwall consists of
two sergeants and 11 licensing officers
and four admin ladies okay so we work
with 11 authorities throughout Deon and
Corall um across the two counties and
we're responsible for monitoring nearly
13,000 license
premises our role is both proactive and
reactive encompassing prevention and
possible cure when Mo most people think
of licensed premises they just think of
pubs and the sale of alcohol but we' be
surprised what activities need to be
licensed all FES who undertake what is
called a license of activity must be
licensed the licens of activities are
the sale of alcol late night
Refreshments so basically late night
takeaways um and regulated entertainment
like Live recorded music but also things
like boxing and
plays all licenses are issued by
yourselves local Authority in which the
premise um is situated and this is where
the first part of our proactive
prevention work comes in so when someone
wants to open a new license and then
Chris and I are going to two people
tomorrow um that want to open a license
premise so we work in conjunction so
when we go out we look at so the
application comes
in then um as as we are responsible
Authority the police
so the um the authority is with the
chief Constable of police um and the
force licensing officers act on behalf
as a designated
power when we receive the application we
look at what the applicant wants to do
what the um the licensable activities
what hours they want to do and and this
can arrange from a 10 cover restaurant
to a nightclub that you know can hold
about 5,000
people the applicant has to demonstrate
that they will promote what is called
the licens and objectives so the
prevention of crime of disorder the
prevention of public nuisance Public
Safety and the prevention of of children
from harm so as you can
imagine it's very very simple people
think it's a dark art it's not a dark
art it's very simple as long as they
abide by those license and
objectives so this is when one of the
main prevention parts of our job comes
in we assess the application against
these objectives and if we are not
satisfied we will ask for additional
restrictions on the license those are
known as conditions so when you look at
premise of license the first part is
basically the statutory I.E the level of
you know how much you put in a drink etc
etc you can't
um dispense alcohol if you haven't got a
DPS a DPS is in our old language is what
we call a landlord land lady designated
premises
supervisor okay so you have a premises
license holder so for example weather
spoons is a premises license holder and
then each weather spoons has a DPS a
designated premise supervisor
okay so we can look at preventative
conditions for example the use of
plastic glasses no drinks served in
bottles uh thorough staff training uh
the use of SIA siia are what we call
door staff okay um drug policies
CCTV is a big thing of the moment and
I'll come on to that in a minute and no
vertical
drinking everyone knows no vertical
drinking no right
okay yeah so if you're in a pub people
stand up but what they're saying is if
it's a
restaurant you have to be sat down when
you drink you can't be stood at a bar
but that that can be one of your
conditions on on your license I know
it's I've I've never I I wouldn't well
anyway we ask these things um to prevent
problems in the future if the
application doesn't agree with the
conditions being put on their license
from myself it's a two-way process they
might say I don't like this I don't like
that I said unlucky we want those
conditions because what we like to do is
we like to Future proof a license okay
so for example if you've got a really
well-run establishment and you've got a
very strong DPS that's great and they
work on those
conditions but if a brewery or that
person moves on and they want to put
another DPS in there and the D PS isn't
as strong then you have to make sure
that those conditions are stringent
enough that they have to abide by does
that make sense
cool um and if they don't agree with the
conditions being put on the license we
can go to a hearing um with with a
licensing
committee so that's one of the main
proactive preventative parts of our job
we also follow the same process for
large events organizers and we have what
we call an events management plan an EMP
so for
example
shedfest shedfest they have an EMP Chris
and I went out and we viewed what they
were doing they have a premises license
because they applied for it so they've
already got a premises license so we we
discuss the conditions Etc but then they
have have to have an events management
plan so if they have a large event and
that that and that will incorporate a
traffic management plan it would
incorporate what first aid they've got
how many Marshals and door staff they
have etc
etc we also deal with events manage um
with temporary events
um um tens basically where you can have
up to 499
people um and then we have lots of those
we have lot of tens that come through
our
system um
so every morning when I come on
duty I check police
logs so I I cover at the moment I cover
torage North Devon um a little bit of
mid Devon a little bit of West Devon and
at the moment a little bit of North
cornall so I'll cover quite a big
area I do a lot of driving
um so when I when I look at a place
log um what happens if there's an in if
there's an incident that's happened
inside a license premise it will create
and it will create what we call an L10
so an officer will let me know via email
and then what will happen then is I will
look at that um I will look at that
premise so making sure that they're
promoting their licens and
objectives and what we have we have an
escalation process and the escalation
process is interest concern action plan
problem solving profile review so for
example if you H have a premise it comes
to your attention they do an L10 I go I
go and visit and I say right the issue
is on this police log we had this
incident has occurred okay there might
have been a crime there or they're not
called crimes now they're called
occurrences don't go there um and then
what happens then is I update the police
log I update the occurrence of what I've
done invariably I will let Chris and the
team know of of subject premises um and
I'll use an example in a
minute so what happens then is if
a interest concern an action plan so we
get the DPS to write an action plan how
are they going to rectify their problem
they have to write it
themselves sometimes we bypass an action
plan because we
know that they're not going to instigate
anything anyway so I write a problem
solving profile and invariably what I do
is they have to apply to vary their
conditions
I want CCTV and I want a lot you know
and there's a lot of conditions you can
put on for
CCTV they have to pay 8 £89 Chris for a
minor variation they can and say right
there you go those are what the
conditions you need to put on your
license if they turn around and say I'm
not doing that that's fine I'll take
them to review so from a police
perspective I do a report send it to
Chris go to review and then it goes in
front of yourselves and then I give my
evidence and then you decide whether
they can stay open so either the licy is
removed I the DPS further conditions are
on the license which I probably put in
the problem solving profile a reduction
in hours of
operation and ultimately the revocation
of the
license um and obviously you can choose
any of these that you you you would feel
fit um moving away from the licenses
themselves we work in partnership with
trading standards at the moment I'm
working quite a lot with trading
standards referen test purchasing and
come in an example in a minute we also
work with the security industry um uh
monitoring uh door
staff I'll very quickly sort of come out
of that
I've got a it's one of my little babies
is the
Saia if you want to become aors indor
staff then what you have to do is you
have to do a standard DBS
check my issue is I reckon I together
with the local representative the SAA
think it should be enhanced because if
it's
enhanced you you the the breadth of the
um the checks a lot bigger because as we
know and I know from experience a lot of
sias have been in trouble with the
police in some guys so as a result of
which I'm always I I want to make sure
that if you've got a door staff on the
front of a pub and you want to know that
they're going to be dealing with it
properly
if for
example you've got a door staff and he's
got a previous criminal history for
domestic assaults or assaults on females
you're not going to feel that
comfortable are you so as a result of
which I I'm quite hot and all the door
companies
know in in our area that I'm quite hot
on that as well H and um at at the
moment I've got rid of five Dorman I.E
we got rid of that we got rid of their
badges anyway so I deal with them and I
also deal with a local Authority ehos on
nuisance and ASB complaints in relation
to V violence against women and girls um
in the late um nighttime economy we work
in partnership with premises especially
we are are involved in any application
for a license which means we can attempt
to limit the number of premises in the
area we can also have an input a local
Authority statement of licens in
principle so for example
um has it gone it's still a consultation
isn't it
Chris oh right okay I'll be quiet now
then so basically there are a couple of
things that I suggested that went on
onto the policy and it and it's and it's
stuff that that I've come across since
been the last inent officer I was was a
uniform police officer for 21 years
predominately in this Force but also TS
Valley transferred retired in 2019 been
doing this job
since love it it's great and and as
Chris knows I just talk and I do
apologize if I'm detracting but there
you go and I think a lot of it is is
you're able um you're able to do um able
to chat to lenes sometimes my I think
very
fine the department also um instigated
the drink spiking initiative um
so we we have an incident should we say
in a pub in bitterford at the
moment so basically what
happens oh no no no no no no no no no
not at all okay and what happens is if
someone thinks theyve been spiked
they call
us we go to the relevant premise we
speak to the relevant premise and one of
the big things is
CCTV that premise doesn't have
CCTV okay so any evidence that happened
inside that premise we we haven't
captured okay what happens then is the
individual um gives a urine sample and
the urine sample is dip sampled and it
comes up with
an array of of drugs that can be used
and it it was positive okay however
there is a there is an investigation at
the moment of which I'm part of and as a
result of which we we um
we I I try and support premises as much
as I can but they they have guidelines
and they know what those guidelines are
and if they go beyond those guidelines
they get dealt with
as as we previously said uh we're also
involved in the project n ey and ask
Angela project n ey is um a g against
violence against women um we also assist
local policing teams with pubs against
drugs operations and I had a meeting
this morning hence there reason I was
slightly late because we're trying to
get a drugs dog to
do what we're going to do is we're not
concentrating on balanceable on this one
we concentrating on bford and ilum so we
want a a proactive drugs dog it's a
passive drugs
dog how they do it I don't know they're
fantastic animals they will just go in
and they will indicate if anyone's got
drugs so that's that's what we that's
the reason we had it as well and we're
also on about the um the lift Legend
campaign is where you can go into a
licensed premise you can ask I'm going
to be the the the um the resp
responsible driver so therefore they can
give them soft
drinks I eat for free and and there are
quite a few pubs in bidford and
Torrington and holsworthy that have have
signed up to this so they give soft
drinks so that's that's a that's a
bonus right
um so it's the way I see it is an
enforcement through
Administration um and um that's it so if
I if I just for example Chris and I
going out tomorrow we're doing two
licensed premises new licenses and then
we're going to some other areas within
torage that we've had some issues with
um um and I W there was a an incident
that happened where a 15-year-old girl
um got very life-changing injuries where
she was a front seat passenger in a
vehicle and it transpires that her and
the driver were both drinking in
pubs and um uh we have CCTV evidence of
of of that as well so a 15-year-old and
one of the big things is proxy
buying you know I'm at an age where my
dad bought me half a larer and a packet
of crisp and I sat in the garden all
weathers that's what he just did wasn't
it but you can't do that yeah you have
to be a certain age and quite rightly as
well part the L and objectives is
prevention of hun to children so so
we're investigating that and then we're
going to some other places as
well and and you appreciate torage and
and was highlighted by yourself sir was
it doesn't get the the place that we
would want you know you want place that
there as well to deal with incidents we
haven't got it and that's that's
something that's um that is um is
frustrating for me being a police
officer a retired police officer it's
also frustrating for my uniform
colleagues as well because they they
want to get out there but they're
beholden by filling in copious amounts
of paperwork goodness knows why but they
are
um you mentioned about the CSP me
meeting um just to let you know Toby is
the only police officer that chairs a
CSP meeting in the whole of the
force no one else no and he was at a
point where he wasn't going to share it
because he wanted um one of the Lo
someone from the local authorities to to
chair it but Toby is so passionate about
it that's why he's decided to still stay
as the
chair I have um some
um some cards that I wrote out last
night because I'm not grown up enough
for them to me provide me business cards
so I've got a load there and I will um
leave them there if people want to pick
them up as they go out that's my work
mobile if you want to contact me just
leave a message or leave a text message
and then I'll get back to you when I'm
on
duty are there any questions probably
are
C the
Engish large events license sorry large
event license yes a recently bford
Carnival for instance right and I know
they were put through quite a
vigorous uh meeting before it took place
regarding safety
Etc um I'd like to know what do you come
and
check the event when it's taking place
because I've been to other carnivals
and it seems to me that a lot of things
are going on that shouldn't
be and I think this should be
highlighted okay that is probably
something that might be might could be
um highlighted in the CSP events
management plan will normally go to a
sag safety Advisory Group Chris sits on
it I sit on it and and then any resp you
know anyone so for example highways are
invited ehos are in invited they're all
invited and and then um and we also have
a strategic planning officer as well
from the police and they come up with
these that's all they do so they come up
with what about this this and this I
know what it's quite bizarre what they
come up with but I can understand why
they because they want to make sure that
everyone is is safe IE the separation
they might have two sites Etc so they
want to make sure that that the the the
the footfall between one and the other
is not going over a road and if they are
going over a road is there a Marshall
there to you know prevent any road
traffic collisions Etc so I understand
that as
regarding shed I I will I go if there's
a large event I will go and and I don't
tell the organizers I just turn
up because and if I'm doing a visit and
visit it's um if it's a pre-planned one
then Chris and I will go reference the
two ones we've got tomorrow for the new
licenses we'll go one in W and one in
here and we'll go however if it if it's
other premises that you not want to
catch them out but you want to make sure
that they're they're carrying out their
their function I.E the four licens and
objectives and if they're not then they
get they get suitably advised should we
say but as regarding large events I try
and go to to them as well Mrs Butler's
not happy about it but you know there
you go she gets dragged along this L
sorry councelor
penon um thank you for your I'm really
honest and I I appreciate all the work
you're doing um and having said some
comments previously I you got a lot of
respect for the police so I don't want
to get into a lot of difficult no I I I
I fully understand I was going to ask um
your your um title was police licensing
officer yes are you funded by the police
or are you funded by the local
authorities police you're funded by the
police
yes okay that's just and I've never
realized your Ro was here before so and
I'm on the licensing committee for
goodness sake you know so I thank you
for your report this morning it's my
first time on licensing committee by the
way because I'm a Methodist and I was T
toal many years ago but not now so there
you are
but that's the way that one goes you
know from that point of view um you join
the young
Farmers that's right that's right I gave
up smoking at 15 but that's the way that
went I suppose but um um all I'm saying
I wanted to ask also from from the point
of view I notice in our review which is
agenda item 11 a lot of the stuff in
yellow which we are taking out we' we
revolves around uh uh mistreatment of
the female do you agree that that should
be taken out when we look at our review
in a minute on on uh as regarding
violence against women and girls
sorry is that what we're talking
about putting it in you put it in okay I
thought that was what the yellow was
taking out okay it's going in right no
so my question is why is there not the
same balance towards the male of the
population
okay if if I had and also as as police
staff we have problem
solvers these problem Sol has come up
with the violence against women and
girls which is a national um uh bought
in by AO Association chief police
officers basically
is the vast majority are female I mean
it's about 82% of female and there are a
very small percentage of males now we
fully answer %
18% unless you
got yeah so what what I I try what we
try and do is we make anyone aware for
example we have an arandela arandela
basically is if if anyone goes to a door
goes to any door staff and we talked
about siia earlier on making sure you
feel comfortable but any staff member
and say can I is Angela in basically
what happens then is the staff or aware
of it they will take that individual to
one side and I'll give you an
example we had one in in in a town not a
million miles away from here where a
female had obviously gone onto a a
internet first
date the the male was odd so she's gone
to the felt uncomfortable went to the do
um to the staff and said is Angela in
they've taken her out of the back and
then the the individual the male ended
up getting arrested because he went
bansai because if you know this female
had gone so it's for
fortuitous but anyone anyone and that's
one I've got a meeting this afternoon
with a licensing um uh licensing meeting
in in barable and and that's one of the
things that we we we we talk about so
yes I I quite agree with you and I I
beat that beat that drum as well it's
not all necessarily about females but
the large percentage are females and the
example is the two females operation Los
Angeles and middle witch in bable and
obviously and and and there and that's a
prime example is the offender do you
know what his job was
his job was his security at bille
magistrates
court so he was an
SAA all right so hence the reason say
all this is my evidence a report to the
Saia to say it needs to be enhanced
because the the difference between a
standard DBS and an enhanced DBS is
negligible as an individual because at
average they get paid 22 an
hour thank you very much all
right oh yeah very thank you very much
that um Paul I really enjoyed the
information in that um I think the ask
Angela initiative that's that's really
good because I had heard I don't know if
it was even Angela but similar
initiative around the country but it
just seems to have faded away to nothing
so actually have it written in the
policy that from now on you know we
licenses will have to have that that's a
really good move forward
definitely and and what you going to be
very mindful of
is
breweries breweries do change their
dbs's quite frequently because they find
out that they're not selling as much
beer so the brewery will find an excuse
to get rid of a DPS if you've got a
really good DPS we had a really good DPS
in one PB doing really well Brewery got
rid of him put someone else in there
that would sell you know they'd sell a
very very drunk person alcohol because
it it's a profit and that's what the
breweries so I'm very mindful about
breweries as well about how how they how
they um not not say modern slavery but
they they do take full advantage of of
not
necessarily C p in you come
Sor I that is the same issue with
gambling isn't it because you got the
gambling um industry who want to you
know their best paying customers the
ones that put the themselves in huge
debt and your same principle here and
and we are licensed authorities and and
the vulnerability is the best paying
pubs or the best paying booking offices
are the ones that bend the rules and
you're always trying to fight that and I
you have a problem on your hands um
simply because they have to make a
profit exactly and have to make it
within the law and there is a very
narrow line to walk it seems to me and I
think the gambling industry actually is
more of a mess than than than the
alcohol industry because people are are
losing their homes effective I think
because we're becoming quite stringent
about how they operate for example
they're they're more for so
stonate as we know are a national brand
they own you know they run wet Le pubs
and what they do is they they'll lease
out a pub to for example craft Union so
craft Union have got the lease for that
Pub and then they put a DPS in so what
you do is if you don't get a lot of Joy
from a DPS you speak to craft
Union Give an example if you speak to
craft Union you don't get a great deal
out of craft Union you go straight to
stonate and I've I know the region
manager for the south of England for
stonate so I just phone Alan up and I go
Alan just to let you know um you'll be
amazed on how how quick that goes
because he knows they don't want us to
close
pubs you know and then if if we put a
load of conditions on you know through a
problem solving profile then that's what
I'll do and he knows I'll do that hence
the reason he makes sure that people are
abiding by the rules that's all I want
people to do yes I want pubs to stay
open I also want them to play by the
rules you know all right cool thank you
very much for your time is the
morning see you again if I leave I'll
leave those there please just give us a
bell or email me then I will I will
return your call I do I've got already
five Miss messes messages on the phone
so D people excellent thank you very
much
cheers and now we are going back to
item nine I believe it was on
it which is the I can't scroll fast
enough uh licens in act policy
review you want to take that one yeah
thank you chair um yes this is the
licensing policy um which is for review
the current statement expires in January
2024 um at the meeting on the 21st of
June 23 the committee approved to go out
to consultation which we've now done
over an 8we period um it's a bit
disappointing the response we only had a
response from from Paul Butler he's just
been here now um and it was sent out to
all all license premises is um
advertised on the internet and intranet
and um but yes it's not unusual that we
don't get a lot of response there's no
major policy
changes um but all the all the changes
are highlighted in yellow so I don't
propose to go
through the whole document it's quite a
long
document um so I will just run down we
have got a
the summary of the proposed changes if I
just go down the pages if anybody's got
any particular issue with that page if
you want to is probably the best way of
doing it I'll just run down through the
pages anybody wants to comment on that
page put your hand
up I'm putting it in all the yellow
unless it's crossed
out there is some Crossings out that's
coming out but the majority is stuff
going
in so yeah I'll just run through
obviously the first lot is just
um so page two is just
updates
um and Page Three is guidance page four
is
statistics page five is just dates um
page seven is just updating policies and
strategies I'm actually these Pages I'm
referring to the actual page of the
document not the um not just to confuse
you it's not the ACT agenda
pages hold on let me catch up on my
agenda then I can give you the correct
page numbers yes so page 19 of the
agenda that's the guidance which is just
um General
updates um page 20 no changes 21 we've
just taken out some specific in there's
some specific detail there of how we
look at um applications and how we
divide responsibilities it's a bit
restrictive so we've left it a bit
open-ended so we got a bit more scope of
how we do that um um 22 is again minor
changes just a few extra words in the
safety advisor groups which Paul alluded
to earlier um the pspo now covers a
little bit extra area than it used to 23
is the
same bottom of 24 there's the new
planning act well business and planning
act which is payment licenses basically
that's been extended again to the end of
2024 um there's some new legislation on
counterterrorism coming in that's not
been implemented yet but I've future
proofing the policy and putting it in um
and that will provide more detail as
time goes
on um page 25's just uh a minor
alterations there um it shows how old
the policy is back at page B page 25 it
says about a fax machine I don't think
we've had a fax machine for I don't know
how many years
so um 26 no changes
27 28
29 um 30 is just a new paragraph Just
providing additional information on
disapply in conditions for Community
premises
um page
31 is removal of
specifically related bford Town Center
we used to have a high number of
premises but they have reduced
significant over over time so that's not
so
relevant 32 and 33 no changes
34 is some information provided by Paul
Butler relating to psychoactive
substances so we just update a few
paragraphs there um 35 includes a new
paragraph on beer
gardens um and outdoor spaces with the
Advent of Co the use of beig Gardens and
outdoor spaces has increased so there's
some more guidance on there for
applicants and that carries on to page
36 uh 37's the
same
38 is the initiatives that Paul's
discussed earlier it's the um targeting
violence against women and girls ask
Angela um anti-spike drink
spiking initiative
um and I think that's it 41 42 43 and 44
yes so that is the sum of the proposed
amendments the policy does have to go to
full Council for full approval so the
licensing committee can only approve it
um to go to full Council for final final
approval which is in the act in the
licensing Act full Council has to
approve the final policy so any any
questions
queries councelor D I think you first
yeah Chris what is um the abbreviation
tens T is temporary event notice thank
you councelor
pton thank you um thank you for the
report I apologize that I read it the
wrong way around okay I do register my
concern that it focuses on the female
yes okay and I want that recorded but I
will vote along I'm not going to go for
but it does strike me and by definition
82% of offenses as Paul talked about 18%
then must be male from that point of
view um the thing that struck me most of
all in this policy is on page on bottom
of the page 13 of the agenda we've got
and it's very first page the licensing
act 2003 statement of license policy for
the period 24th of uh 7th of January 24
to 29 and then I go to the bottom of the
page and I realize that the last full
Council didn't have a chance to look at
the licensing policy because it was
adopted on the 18th of December 2018
prior to the four years of
period and then it the hold of that
Council never looked at the licenses
policy
once and it's only now in this new
Council because you have a
fiveyear cycle so that
every every fifth
Council doesn't own its licensing policy
and I wonder why we don't have a
four-year licensing policy so that every
Council can come and then pick up these
issues and there's been tremendous
changes in the last four years of the
council with Co and all the other things
that were going on and we have to be
more fluid and give new members the
chance and I wondered if I what your
thoughts were if we went back to for
year cycle and it came up at the
beginning of every new Council so every
new
member adopts the policy and you're not
in a situation then where a council
never ever looks at the policy in the
whole of that four-year period now I
wonder what your thoughts chair or
officer from that point of view would be
please the fiveyear period is stated in
the licensing act it does say that the
policy must be reviewed every five
years I don't see reason why we could do
it in less than five years as long as we
do it within that fiveyear period
there's no reason and there's no reason
why we can't review a policy midterm as
well and update
it um so I can't see any
issues unless there's anything from a
legal point of view but I can't see any
reason why we can't at the beginning of
a new Council bring the existing policy
to the council even if it's not even if
it's not reviewed at that time at least
it's brought to the attention of the
full Council if they do want to make any
amendments there's no reason why they
can't make midterm amendments so to
speak so it would be fairly
straightforward to bring a review
forward not like the joint planning
policy committee where we jump through
hoops to get anything coming on stream
if we have felt something there's been a
change in society for whatever reason
and everybody's going for outdoor
festivals um and shefest happens in
every village you know I mean yeah and
that's the the the policy is there to
evolve as well and to and to be up to
date if it those five years A lot can
happen in five years can it so if there
is any that suddenly comes up that needs
review there's no reason why it can't
brought so we as a council can easily
bring forward and request a review yes
yes that thank you yeah cool um I was
just going to bring up about the
psychoactive substances in part of it it
says removed a bit about um uh seeking
advice from local drugs action team I'm
assuming because that's been yeah that's
been
dissolved a replacement team they're not
clearly designated as a drugs action
team now is
generally still within the police but
it's generally rather than being
referred to exactly as the team it's
more generic yeah still someone still
covering those issues that they would do
officers councelor
level
I I think I heard caught on the news
this morning um that nitrous oxide they
Chang the law haven't they on on the use
of nitrous oxide to make it illegal to
use it if it's not um I don't know if
that I haven't really had time to read
what it said about nitrous oxide but
yeah I know they are I'm not sure if
it's actually come in yet um I they are
looking you know how you have breakfast
news yeah they looking they are looking
to actually making it
illegal to for any other reason than
medical or whatever it's useful I don't
even know what it's used for sorry but I
think it's they're changing the law on
it don't
it's anyone else got no more comments
I'll propose from the chair that we
accept this and um make a recommendation
that full Council accepts it I got a
second Steve Council Harden was slightly
quicker
there and we'll go to a vote all in
favor marvelous that's what I like to
see thank you very much and we go to the
top of the page
again right we are um forward
plan to the B
again must be a quick way doing this
uh
um forward plan we've got nothing on the
forward plan we've got nothing in for no
we have discussed about the car park
spaces so I can Lea with um Devon County
and our own car Parks team so we can
bring back a taxi update um and I'll see
if there's anything else coming forward
that we can include on the agenda I'll
I'll LE review chair um if there is
anything coming forward and we'll we'll
go from there is it wor up the um sub
committee at this point or we'll do that
after the
meeting in that case if we've covered
all the all
positions I'll say this is a Mee is
closed it's 11:28